i think that asking what caused the
civil war is the wrong question
and um even some of your new
abolitionist historians like ken stamp
and eric foner
have pointed out that they're really two
separate questions
why does the south succeed and why does
the north refuse to let the south go
so what was the beginning of his
presidency like uh well
um the beginning of his presidency uh is
um uh dominated by the
uh uh secession of the deep south
so how soon after he was inaugurated um
well after he's elected um
the deep south succeeds with south
carolina being the first state
and then you have the cotton states
um seceding was he even inaugurated at
that no no they did not that was
right after the last that's incredible
by the way one interesting detail
that a lot of people are unaware of in
south carolina's ordinance of secession
um and they're the first state they're
the they're the most fire brand of
all the secessionists
in their ordinance of secession they do
not
the the issue they give the largest play
to in terms of justifying secession
is not lincoln's election but northern
failure to comply with the fugitive
slave
clause of the constitution now partially
that's
a rhetorical ploy because it allows them
to argue that the northerners
had had violated the constitutional
contract
first but it also reflects a deep
concern about
um fugitive slaves and
and one of the one of the um
points that i make in my book is that i
think most historians have
underestimated the economic significance
of the
of the fugitive slave issue in terms of
uh bringing on
secession and maybe we can get to no no
i i do want to get to that so
um so so you have the deep south
succeeding and they're seizing
all of the us military bases
except for a few that are holding out
and the prominent one that's holding out
is fort sumter
in charleston harbor so james buchanan
has to deal with this
he's the lame duck president he tries to
reinforce
sumter and south carolina fires on the
ship and so
but the garrison is still there when
lincoln it becomes president
so that's the big issue that's
dominating uh lincoln's presidency is
what do you what do you do about fort
sumter
and um uh
uh lincoln um you know
he's getting all kinds of advice uh
some people want him to try to
um back down on the republican position
about slavery in the territories but he
absolutely refuses to do so i mean he's
he has agreed to enforce the fugitive
slave act as president
so it's this is the only anti-slavery
issue
right and and he decides to hang on to
it
um and some want a more aggressive
policy someone a more passive policy
basically um lincoln
essentially follows um buchanan's policy
although buchanan gets a lot of
criticism yeah i was just gonna ask you
that um
and what happens is well buchanan's
policy being what
being uh trying to reinforce the fort
but
not using military force to
um to to uh um
hold on to the fort gotcha all right so
uh lincoln sends
um reinforcements and supplies to the
fort
uh telling the south carolina that he's
doing so by this time the confederacy
has formed the confederacy fires on fort
sumter
right and and that's the that's the 911
of the civil war
it polarizes both sides um
it polarizes uh northerners because
there are
up until this time there are a lot of
northerners who say well we should let
the south go in peace many of them think
well if we let them go in peace they'll
come back
and at the time of lincoln's
inauguration there's still more slave
states in the union than out of the
union
but lincoln responds to the firing on
fort sumter by calling out
troops and immediately
virginia north carolina
tennessee and arkansas all joined the
confederacy so it
it it yeah it's the great divide
um with a stroke of the pen he's he's
doubled the size and the material
resources of the confederacy
yeah what do we know about his thought
process at the time was he
really ready for the fallout that was
going to happen
um yes and no and then the escalation
obviously
yes and no let me back up a little and
explain why he had to do this
all right why it was politically
necessary to do this
many of your abolitionists particularly
william lord garrison who's one of my
heroes
who was advocated a media emancipation
full political rights for all
african americans he was also a pacifist
an anarchist a classical liberal in
favor of free trade
free labor
his opposition to slavery a lot of the
radical abolitionists
framed it as man stealing
you know in terms of uh property rights
and he was also in favor of northern
secession
from the union because he saw the
constitution as a pro-slavery document
uh he um denounced the uh
constitution um publicly burned a copy
and on the masthead of his of his paper
that liberator
no union with slaveholders um graced it
throughout uh from 1831 on up to the
civil war
and and this was true of many of your
most radical abolitionists
so um basically what your abolitionists
and one of the reasons they were so
unpopular is because they were saying
you can't have anti-slavery and union
uh and uh people are committed to the
union
right so they're not happy about the
amplitude the republican party by
reducing um the anti-slavery issue to
its lowest common denominator in the
territories
is telling the public you can have
anti-slavery in union all right well
once the union's threatened the
republican party
is going to have to suppress secession
or face political oblivion
and in fact even if stephen douglas had
been elected president
he's an old hard-line jacksonian he had
been elected president
and the south had still seceded now
that's not very likely
but if he had been elected president and
the staff had seceded he probably would
have
moved uh military force against the
south even faster than lincoln
it's so interesting because i think one
of the themes as we
do this whole week is looking at these
people through a 2018 lens and when you
hear
that somebody didn't want full rights
for people but wanted to free them or
they couldn't vote or some of the other
issues you're talking about
and yet at the same time you're saying
but the abolitionists actually weren't
that popular
right it's like to give to view these
people through our lens today
is really it's a very slippery slope
because lincoln had to do some things
that perhaps
in our lens now would have been viewed
as very unfair
to the african-american right yeah and
there he was so okay so
the the war begins and he said he's a
new president at
war uh who is he getting advice from
where like did he really understand how
to
okay well the other part of the answer
to your question is
that um
lincoln and many of the republicans and
many northerners in general
underestimated
the enthusiasm for secession
on the part of southerners they believed
initially believed that it was
a southern elite of slaveholders almost
a conspiracy that had brought about
secession
and that and that's why
they weren't prepared
for the extent of the redis resistance
of
uh southerners uh once lincoln
uh calls out troops yeah and so
once he calls out troops then
then you have the problem of managing
the war so there was really nothing he
could have done at that point even
even if there were voices even if he
internally felt well maybe we could just
let them go
or if he had voices around him that were
saying ah you know sorry let them secede
it was too late really right yeah
politically yeah all right politically i
mean
by that time uh in the north at least
not not in the deep south but in the
north
liberty and union had become mystically
identified
as inseparable and
and so that's um
and in fact right this leads to the
question
of uh the a more basic question of what
caused the civil war
right and there's now a current trend
to argue that slavery caused the civil
war and not only it caused the civil war
but it was all about
slavery uh and that in fact slavery
um the entire history of the union up
until that point is all about slavery
you disagree with that and i did i just
take it away
um i think that asking what caused the
civil war
is the wrong question and um
even some of your new abolitionist
historians like ken stamp and eric foner
have pointed out that they're really two
separate questions
why does the south succeed and why does
the north refuse to let the south go
and the answer to the first question is
definitely slavery
i mean the evidence is overwhelming for
that there's probably hardly
any um historical causal explanation at
that level of abstraction for which
um the evidence is more overwhelming so
the south secedes in order to protect
slavery
okay so that's an easy one but ending
slavery
is not what motivates the north yeah
what motivates the north is preserving
the union
and in fact lincoln um
uh in the uh before the firing on fort
sumter
endorses a original 13th amendment
which is not passed in which he's still
holding to the position of opposing the
extension of slavery in the territories
but this new amendment would protect
slavery
in the existing slave states and be
unamendable
in the early days of the war
some of your union commanders were
returning runaway slaves
so um so so
so the war from the union perspective
the suppression of secession
is designed to preserve the union and
lincoln even later says if he could
preserve the union by
freeing all the slaves he'll do that if
he could preserve the union by freeing
some
and none of the slaves he'll do that if
he can preserve the union by freeing
some
and and leaving others enslaved he would
do that
what was his real belief in the union
based in
did he did he just truly believe that we
had to remain
one country otherwise we would be in
perpetual war
is that yeah yeah yeah yeah he thought
that the the
disillusion of the union would lead to
anarchy
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell